the Continental is a chain of hotels
around the world that cater exclusively
to members of the underworld they offer
a variety of services such as Weapons
Medical Care information and even
tailoring but the most important feature
of the Continental is that it's a safe
haven for Assassins no one is allowed to
conduct any business which means no
killing on the hotel grounds the markers
are metal tokens that serve as a record
of the Blood Oath between two parties in
the Underworld they're used when one
party asks a significant favor from
another party and the other party agrees
to Grant it in exchange for anything
they want in return at any time the high
table is the supreme authority of the
underworld it's a council of 12 powerful
crime Lords who rule over their
respective territories and factories
around the world they set and enforce
the rules that govern all aspects of
life and death in the Underworld the
soup kitchen is a vast intelligence
Network run by the bowy king in New York
it masquerades as a homeless shelter and
consists of many agents in the form of
homeless people ex communicado is the
status of an assassin who has been
expelled from the underworld for
breaking the rules it means that they
lose all access to the continental and
its services